J. MICHAEL MDBRIDE: So,
we'll finish up on
NMR spectroscopy, talking
about more dynamic things
involving decoupling.
Then a little bit about C-13 NMR
and double labeling
involving correlation.
And then we'll get onto another
reaction,
electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
OK, so proton decoupling.
Remember that the proton is four
times as strong a magnet
as the Carbon-13, so it
precesses much faster.
So it's easy to do a pulse that
will tilt the Carbon-13
net magnetization down into the
plane, so that it'll
precess and be an antenna that
can tell us its local field
without doing the same thing to
the proton.
And if we do that, then we see
the C-13 NMR spectrum.
And there are two peaks, because
of
the adjacent proton.
Right? it can be either up or
down, 50:50
or almost exactly 50:50
so you see two peaks.
Now suppose at the same time
you're doing that, when you do
this pulse and listen to the
C-13 to see what its local
field is, you irradiate at 100
MHz.
Right?
That won't do anything to the
C-13,
it's the wrong frequency.
But it'll now make the proton
precess.
That is, if we look in the
rotating frame, we can see a
weak field that's horizontal,
about which the
magnetism will precess.
So the protons will go down, and
then up, and then down,
and then up.
And what determines how fast it
goes up and down?
How strong this field is.
The stronger it is, the faster
it will precess.
And if it's fast enough, then
you won't see a doublet for
the C-13 anymore, because you'll
see the average.
Right?
So you'll see a single peak,
you'll proton-decouple the
C-13 spectrum and see the C-13
as if the
protons weren't there.
OK, so it depends on how much
power you put in.
Now here's a C-13 spectrum of a
given compound.
Where we're listening to the
C-13 and we see all these
different local fields, right?
But we're irradiating the proton
at the same time, but
very, very weakly.
This number up there, 40
decibels, is an inverse ratio
of how strong that horizontal
field is for the protons.
So it's 10-4th weaker than what
you'll see you
later, 10,000 times weaker.
And if we look at the carbon, we
see that some of the carbon
signals are split and some are
not split.
The ones that are split are the
ones that have
hydrogens on them.
So if we start from the left, we
see there's one with no
hydrogens, then one with one
hydrogen,
one with one hydrogen.
That red one is the solvent
CDCl3, right?
So we're looking at the carbon
of the CDCl3.
But it has a deuterium on it,
not a
hydrogen, so it's not split.
Then there's a carbon with two
hydrogens, a carbon with three
hydrogens, it's a quartet.
Underneath, a carbon with two
hydrogens, it's a triplet.
So very low power in the proton,
that's what we see.
Now we're going to reduce the
size of that.
And see what happens, is we
start increasing the power.
So there's 40 dB, 20 dB,
and now things are beginning to
change.
See how the patterns are
changing their multiplicity
and their intensity?
Because it turns out that when
you irradiate the protons by a
complicated mechanism it
strengthens the signal of the
carbons to which they're
coupled.
And that's called nuclear
Overhauser enhancement, as
you'll see.
OK. So now you see the splitting
is going away when
we get down to two decibels or
one decibel.
Now we see that each carbon
gives just a single peak, we've
decoupled the protons.
So now we have a peak for every
carbon.
And notice, incidentally, that
the CDCl3 didn't get stronger
as we did this.
Why?
Because what strengthened the
signal was irradiating the
protons and CDCl3 doesn't have
hydrogens on it.
So it doesn't get strengthened.
OK, notice also that the carbon
without a hydrogen on
it, on the far left here, didn't
get strengthened as
much as the others did.
OK, so that's decoupling, and it
can be useful.
And it can be useful in several
ways.
There's two things, you get rid
of the spin-spin splitting
so you see just a peak for each
carbon.
And also you strengthen the
signals when
they have nearby protons.
And that could be bad if you're
interested in measuring
the size of the peaks to get how
many carbons there are,
because you can't count properly
anymore because you
get different intensities with
different
neighbors of protons.
But it's good if you want to
determine structure and see
what hydrogens are how far away,
and I'll
show you that shortly.
OK, now bear in mind that
carbon-13 is only 1% in
natural abundance of carbon.
Of course, you can synthesize
the molecule with expensive
carbon-13-containing precursors
and put carbon-13
where are you want it in a
molecule, and then the signal
from that carbon will be ever so
much stronger.
If you put in pure carbon C-13
in some position, the signal
would be 100 times stronger.
In fact, 200 times stronger than
without.
No, pardon me.
It would be 100 times stronger,
because it would be
100% instead of 1%.
OK, so here's a compound,
neotame, it's
an artificial sweetener.
And it's the proton-decoupled
C-13 spectrum.
So you see one peak for each
carbon.
There are 20 carbons, there are
20 peaks.
But you can't go by their
intensities.
Now, let's see what we can make
of this.
It's proton-decoupled, so
there's one peak per carbon
and, being carbon, it's pretty
well spread out.
Remember, the range of hydrogen
chemical shifts is
only about 10 parts per million.
The range for carbon is hundreds
of
parts per million here.
200 parts per million are shown.
Now why is there no C-13-C-13
splitting?
There's no proton splitting
because it's decoupled.
But why no C-13-C-13 splitting?
STUDENT: The likelihood of two
C-13s adjacent in the same
molecule is unlikely.
PROFESSOR: If it's only 1%
natural abundance, and you're
a C-13 so that you're giving a
signal, the chance that your
neighbor is C-13 is only 1%, so
there would be tiny, tiny
peaks from those
you don't see them.
OK, so that's what Chris just
said.
OK now, let's see if we can
figure out which carbons these
are, that we're looking at.
And of course, this is how it
was done empirically.
People put in known compounds
and figured out what the
chemical shifts... what peaks
were from one compound to the
next.
And then they figured out this
comes in this range, this
comes in this range, this comes
in this range.
So let us see, knowing what
these peaks are.
OK first, there are these ones
that are way
down close to 200.
They're numbers 1, 13, and 4.
So what do 1, 13, and 4 have in
common that turns out to
make them way far downfield?
Ellen, what do you say?
What do 1, 13, and 4 have in
common that makes
them different from the
other carbons?
STUDENT: They're almost like
esters.
Like, double bonding to an O.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the double bond
to an O. Carbonyl carbons
are way downfield.
OK, now we've got 7 and 8 to 12.
So there's 7 and there's 8, 9,
10, 11, 12.
Pretty clear what those are,
right?
Those are the ones on a benzene
ring, aromatic carbons.
OK, then there are ones that are
a little bit further down
than the others, and those are
those blue ones.
What do they have in common?
Rahul, what do you say they have
in common?
STUDENT: Tertiary?
PROFESSOR: They're not all
tertiary, no. In fact, only
two of them have three things
associated with them, the
others have one and two.
Lauren, can you see what the
blue ones have in common?
In hydrogen, what makes things
come a
little bit further downfield?
Yeah Amy?
STUDENT: Well, the hydrogen
would be like deshielding from
an oxygen or something, like
nitrogen or oxygen.
PROFESSOR: They all have an
electronegative atom next to
them, right?
Nitrogen or oxygen.
So those are ones. A carbon
that's attached to something
electronegative.
And then, finally, you have the
others, which are attached
only to carbons.
OK, so you could begin to figure
out these, and you can
get tables of what comes where.
And then you can start dealing
with unknown compounds and
figure out what it's telling
you.
But a nice thing about this
proton-decoupled spectrum is
that there's just one peak for
each carbon, and they're well
spread out.
So that it's good to do this
kind of thing.
So those are the alkane carbons.
OK, now the power of
correlation.
Often when you can measure two
things on the same subject
simultaneously, you get a lot
more information than
measuring one, or measuring the
other, or measuring them
independently.
I'll show you that example with
C-13 double labeling and
also in two-dimensional.
As it's called, nuclear magnetic
resonance.
So first, C-13 double labeling.
And we'll talk about lanosterol
biogenesis.
In fact, we already talked about
it, if you look back at
lecture 52.
OK, so remember we got squalene
from isopentenyl
pyrophosphate.
Then it curled around and we had
this complicated thing
where it zipped up going one
way, and then we had all these
rearrangements.
So as we said at that time, this
is the source of
cholesterol and the steroid
hormones.
And it's a very cute story, how
all that rearrangement
took place
OK. But there's a question
whether it's true.
And I said at that time, wait
for NMR. So now we're at NMR,
so you can get the answer.
OK, so you can use
Carbon-13-labeling to figure
this out.
So if you feed the plant that
makes this stuff Carbon-13
labeled isopentenyl
pyrophosphate--
in that particular carbon, that
substituted carbon--
then you can see where that
would appear in the squalene.
According to the way we linked
them together before, it
should be those carbons.
Then when you curl it around and
do all this stuff to make
lanosterol, those peaks should
be labeled with C-13 and
therefore 100 times stronger
than the other
peaks in that spectrum.
And indeed they are.
So that supports it.
Or you could do it a different
way.
You could label the methyl
group.
And if you label the methyl
group, it turns out that those
methyl groups should be labeled
in squalene.
And then if you curl it around,
it should be those
methyl groups.
And indeed, they're 100 times
stronger
than the other signals.
But much more interesting than
this is to do double labeling.
So if you label both, you get
that.
Big deal.
That's just the same information
we got before right?
Except done in one experiment
rather than two.
And, in a sense this is not as
valuable as these
two independent label
experiments, because you don't
know but what two of those
carbons might, in principle,
have changed places.
But the double labeling is much
more important
if you do it dilute.
Now what do I mean dilute?
I've been talking as if we put
100% C-13 in here.
But suppose we don't put nearly
100%, suppose we only
put 10% in.
But suppose that those 10% that
are
labeled are double labeled.
So we prepare a sample that's
100% labeled in two positions,
but then we mix it with 90%
percent of unlabeled material
and feed it to the organism and
get the stuff out.
OK, so what we're going to do is
a dilute double label.
Now why do it dilute?
Because then, when label goes
in, two labels go in.
But it's unlikely that any given
squalene will have two
different positions double
labeled, or two sets of
positions double labeled.
Because only 10% of the stuff is
double labeled.
So when a squalene is double
labeled, it'll be labeled in
just one pair of positions, a
given molecule.
Like there.
So those two come labeled
together.
The signal is 10 times stronger
because
remember, it was 10%.
It's 10 times stronger than it
was for the
ones that aren't labeled.
But what's special about it?
Can anybody see what's going to
be special about the signal
we get from these molecules that
look like that?
Ayesha, have you got an idea?
STUDENT: They're going to be the
same more or less
because they're just an extra--
PROFESSOR: They're going to be
the same what?
STUDENT: They're going to be the
same more or less
because they're just extra
carbons and
there's no special function.
PROFESSOR: I didn't quite
understand you, but I was
listening for special words and
I didn't hear them.
Sebastian, have you got a
special word for us?
STUDENT: You get splitting?
PROFESSOR: Ah, they'll split
each other, because now the
C-13s are next to one another.
Because they're not coming in at
random 10%, they're coming
in as a pair.
So now when we look at the
signal from that, it's going
to be a double doublet.
The blue and the red one are
going to split each other.
Now other molecules in the same
sample will turn out to
have been labeled elsewhere.
For example, so that proves that
those entered as a unit.
Others will have come in there,
and those will also be
a double doublet, show that they
came in as a unit.
And if we go over to the other
end of the molecule, those
will be a double doublet.
And those singles will be a
double doublet.
Great.
What's going to be different?
Suppose we had that molecule
where we had a methide shift.
So the carbon got away from its
original neighbor.
Now it won't be next to a C-13
and it'll be just a pair of
singlets instead of a double
doublet in a
proton-decoupled spectrum.
And the same thing will be true
there.
So this double labeling
absolutely proves that these
rearrangements took place.
So those two, incidentally, are
labeled in the same molecule.
But they're not adjacent to one
another anymore, so they
don't show splitting.
And those are both labeled, the
ones that are adjacent to
one another, but not in the same
molecule.
So they don't do splitting
either.
So this dilute double label
experiment enhances the same
12 peaks as the single label
experiments did, the two
single label experiments.
But only eight of them show
spin-spin splitting because
their bonds stay intact.
So this strongly confirms the
story I told you before about
the rearrangement scheme.
OK, so this is the power of
correlation.
And let's look at a different
kind of power of correlation
in what's called two-dimensional
NMR spectroscopy.
Now here's a two-dimensional NMR
spectrum.
And the way it's collected is
rather technical and we don't
have time to go into it.
But it shows that there are two
different frequencies
being used.
And if you go along the diagonal
of this plot, those
two frequencies are the same.
So what you see there, when you
have just a certain
frequency going in, is the
normal spectrum you see along
the diagonal.
But this is the spectrum of a
protein.
So it's got a whole bunch of
amino acids linked
together like that.
And we're in the range of the
spectrum between 6 and 9,
where the N-H protons show up In
this
particular kind of molecule.
So there are a whole bunch of
them in this long chain and
they all overlap with one
another, and it's very hard to
tell what's going on.
But if you don't have these two
frequencies you're using
the same, you're looking at one
while you're irradiating
another one.
And that affects the intensity
of the one you're looking at.
That's this nuclear Overhauser
enhancement that we talked
about, where you irradiate one,
other things that it's
coupled to will change their
intensity.
So what we're going to do is
plot on the off-diagonal how
one frequency is influenced by
having other frequencies in
there, in its intensity.
So that's called NOE, or nuclear
Overhauser
enhancement.
And it comes, incidentally, by
through-space magnetic
interaction.
Not the stuff like we talked
about coupling where it goes
through bonds.
This works through space.
So it works if the two protons
you're looking at-- the one
you're looking at and the one
you're tickling to see if it
influences this one--
if they're within about 6A of
one another.
So as I said, this is mostly
these N-H protons.
And for one thing, one advantage
of having these off-
diagonal peaks is they're much
less congested than what's
along the diagonal than the
normal spectrum.
So for example, we're looking
here at the NH proton that's
at 7.25 parts per million.
But you can see that it
interacts with
several other protons.
It's within 6A of signals that
are at
8.9, 8.3, 8.25, 7.7.
Now you don't measure the exact
distance, all you know
is that it's close.
But this allows you to make a
three-
dimensional map of the protein.
And the way you do it, is first
you have to know which
NH goes with which R group.
So you see that that NH--
the one you're looking at, the
red one--
is close to that blue one.
So it'll influence it.
But the blue one is then close
to Hs that are in the R group,
so you can tell which R group
that that blue H is nearby,
and which one the red H is near.
So the red is near the blue is
near the R. So you know which
NH is near which R. And now the
way you make a map, then,
in this way--
Professor Loria, who does this
kind of
thing, uses this analogy--
it's like making a map of a town
if all you have is a
telephone and a telephone book.
Sometimes there's a front page
that has a map of the town,
then that's easy.
But if you don't have the map of
the town, then what you do
is you just call someone at
random.
Say, Hi, how are you today?
Blah blah blah.
Could you tell me who three of
your near neighbors are?
And they tell you three of their
near neighbors.
Then you call those people, and
you say Hi, can you tell
me who three of your near
neighbors are?
And they tell you.
And then you call the next one,
Who are three of your
near neighbors?
So once you know who is near
what, then you can see that
there will be a map that will
allow you to figure
out what's near what.
Especially if you have some
help, because you know in the
case of the protons, they have
to fit with normal bond
distances, normal bond angles,
and so on.
So if you do molecular mechanics
together with this
knowing what's near what, you
can get a very good three-
dimensional structure of the
protein.
And the nice thing about this,
from the point of view of
people who are actually working
with proteins-- what's
the best way of getting the
three-dimensional structure of
something like a protein or
anything?
X-ray, but you need a crystal.
For this, you don't need a
crystal.
So you can find the structure
that way.
So with molecular mechanics
constraint, you get the 3D
structure without a crystal.
Now here's a different kind of
2D correlation with NMR. It's
correlation not in space, but in
time.
So this is the spectrum of a
cation, that cation that's
shown at the right.
Notice it's benzene with methyl
groups all around it,
with one extra methyl group and
a positive charge.
Now in fact, you can get this in
solution as long as you
don't have anything that reacts
with cations in there,
that reacts with low LUMO, so
you need very, very non-basic
solvents to do this.
So again, the diagonal running a
different way this time--
the increase in parts per
million is down to the right,
rather than what we usually see,
increasing to the left.
But anyhow, it's color coded,
according to these peaks that
show what they are in the
molecule.
So the scale is slanted and
backwards.
So you see that if you look at
the resonance structures--
that one, that one, that one--
you can see that the blue and
the green are near where
there's positive charge in the
resonance structure.
So they're far downfield, very
deshielded
compared to the others.
Now this can rearrange.
A methide can shift, so one of
the red methyls on the top
shifted to the right.
So now you've changed which
methyl groups
are in which locations.
So now the red one at the top,
this one and this one are now
C, and will be shifted way
downfield.
This one will be shifted
downfield--
what was blue before in the D
position, and so on.
Then this blue one, which was
downfield before is now an A,
it's up here.
So we've changed the locations,
the local
frequencies, the local fields.
So that's a methide shift.
But is it a 1,2 methide shift?
Because it's possible that the
methyl, instead of going just
to its neighbor, would move to
the center of the ring, up
above the center of the ring and
then it
could come down anywhere.
Wouldn't have to come down
adjacent to where it started.
So you could have a 1,anywhere
shift.
Now you can distinguish that and
measure the rates with
this NMR spectrum, this two-
dimensional NMR spectrum.
So again, we're seeing when one
frequency influences another.
Now if a given set of protons
moves from one position to
another, then having been
irradiating one influences
what happens where it ended up.
Because those same protons are
now here.
So here you see off-diagonal
peaks where
one has become another.
So we can see here, for example,
that the proton that
was in position C becomes A. And
that's what happened in
the blue, here, when we had that
1,2 rearrangement.
We can also see that D becomes
B, and that you can see
happened here.
And you can see that B becomes
C. But you notice there's not
A becomes B, A becomes D, or C
becomes D. So you don't have
peaks for some of these patterns
that
you could have done.
Now if you go through a whole
sequence of the these, then
you can start any place and end
any place else.
But it takes a longer time.
So depending on the time scale
of this thing, you can tell
which things happen quickly.
And what happens quickly is a
1,2 shift, not
a 1 anywhere shift.
So again, that's information on
mechanism.
It comes from two-dimensional
NMR spectroscopy.
And it's proton versus proton
correlation in time.
That's, incidentally, just
another visualization of the
same map I showed before, that
shows the peaks on the
diagonals and the off- diagonal
peaks.
OK, now we've finished with NMR.
We'll refer to it again,
but we've finished discussing
it.
And we'll go on to the next
important reaction, which is
electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
We talked about electrophilic
things before.
Remember, electro philic
addition to an alkene.
Now you might think benzene is
an alkene, so you can get
electro philic addition to the
double bonds of benzene, but
you don't get addition.
You get substitution.
So here's an example of
substituting
deuterium for hydrogen.
You put benzene and concentrated
sulfuric acid
that has deuterium in it, and
you get deuterium first in one
position then, of course, in
other
positions in the benzene.
So you can go all the way to
C6D6, that's how you prepare
deuterated benzene if you want
to use it for a solvent for
something, for example.
You can use other electrophiles
as well, not
just D+, you can use NO2+, Br+,
sulphur+-, R+
and RC=O+.
All these things can substitute
for hydrogen, and
we're going to talk about those.
Now, the mechanism is that the
deuterium, D+, the
deuteron, adds to the ring.
But that, notice, changes the
aromatic ring into just a
regular pentadienyl system.
So you lose a lot of resonance
stabilization.
It happens, but it's not very
stable and it'll easily come
off again if there's anything
that can take a proton.
But if you have a very, very
non-nucleophilic, non-basic
solvent, nothing to take it off,
then it can stay on and
in fact it's observable.
You can get spectra of it.
And so in electrophilic addition
to alkenes, the next thing that
happens is a nucleophile would
add, and you'd
lose the double bond.
But here it's easier to lose the
deuteron or, more
interestingly, the proton.
Losing the deuteron would take
you back to
the starting material.
But losing the proton, the H,
then takes you to the
substituted product.
And that's easier than adding a
nucleophile, because you get
back to the aromatic
stabilization, 30
kilocalories.
And remember, we just saw a
spectrum
that looked like that.
When you added not H, but CH3+,
in this case, to the
hexamethylbenzene.
So it's possible to see these
things in NMR. So there's the
benzene, the D+ comes on, we get
that.
Notice that it converts the
aromatic ring into a chain,
destroying the aromaticity.
Let's look at the orbitals that
are involved, just using
this simple Huckel program.
So benzene, we've looked at the
orbitals of that on the
left, and pentadienyl we looked
at before, too
and we see it on the right.
Now, the most interesting
orbital in pentadienyl is the
one that's indicated in yellow
over there.
The highest of the low three
orbitals, and it's at 0.
And you know it's at 0, the same
energy as a P orbital.
How do you know the energy of
that molecular orbital,
consisting of three P orbitals
is the same energy
as a normal P orbital?
Remember, if you make a double
bond and put the two next to
one another, they overlap, one
goes down, one goes up, it's
not to same energy.
But this one has the same energy
as
an isolated P orbital.
How do you know that?
Notice how many nodes are there
in the lowest one, the
one that's about minus two?
How many nodes for the pi
orbitals?
One, two, three, four, five P
orbitals connected in a chain.
How many nodes in the lowest
combination?
STUDENT: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero, except for the
node of the p
orbitals, of course.
So zero.
Then the next one, the one
that's at about -1?
STUDENT: One.
PROFESSOR: One.
How about the ours?
STUDENT: Two.
PROFESSOR: OK, and so there are
two nodes.
Red, white, red on the top.
Now, how do we know the energy
of that?
How much overlap is there?
STUDENT: Zero.
PROFESSOR: None, they're not
next to one another.
So it's the same as an isolated
p orbital at the
Huckel approximation.
OK, so that one is very
interesting, that SOMO.
It's non-bonding in the case
where we have a single
electron in there, which is
what's shown.
So that's the locus of that odd
electron in the free radical.
If we have 5 pi electrons, the
fifth, the one that's in a
pair, is in those three
positions.
Now suppose we're interested in
the cation with five P
orbitals in a row.
So what we're going to do is
just take that electron out.
And where we take it out is now
going to
be a positive charge.
So that's the same as if we put
another electron in, in
the anion, that would be the
locus of the negative charge.
And in the cation, the locus of
the positive charge.
And that's the same thing we'd
get by drawing resonance
structures that show those same
positions having charges
or free radicals in them.
So those are the positions of
positive charge.
And we get the same thing
drawing resonance pictures.
Now consider the influence on
rate of substituting not
benzene, but a benzene that
already has
some X group on it.
Now, a very common thing to have
studied with this was
nitration, because it's such an
easy reaction to do.
It's a very vigorous reagent,
NO2+.
You make it by just having a
mixture of nitric
and sulfuric acid.
You see how you get NO2+ from
that mixture?
It's quite simple.
You get a proton from sulfuric
acid, and it protonates the
OH, and then you lose water.
So you've got NO2+.
So it could be the thing that
comes in and then a proton
comes off from the same
position, and you've got the
substitution.
But now, when you have X in
there, you can get three
different isomers.
Ortho, meta, and para, they're
called.
Notice, incidentally, that NO2+
is an interesting
molecule because it's exactly
the same as CO2, except it
has one more proton in the
nucleus of the central atom.
Nitrogen instead of carbon.
So CO2 has a pair of electrons
in that double bond, a pair of
electrons on the oxygen that are
in the y orbitals,
pointing up and down.
It's also got x orbitals coming
in and out that have
the same kind of thing.
But if we consider just the y
orbitals, that'll be the LUMO.
There are two pairs of
electrons, so the one with no
nodes has two electrons, the one
with one
node has two electrons.
This is the one with two nodes,
no electronics.
So that's the vacant orbital,
the LUMO of NO2+
just like CO2.
So NO2+- attacks, and we can
measure the rate.
Now what we're going to do to
measure the rate--we could do
careful work with a stopwatch
and so on, but there's a
clever way to do it.
Which is to compare two
molecules by doing them both.
Put both in there, and do the
reaction for just a little
while and then kill it.
If you add base, you won't have
the strong acid and the
reaction will stop.
And now see how much of each one
becomes product.
So we get relative rates that
way.
So we're doing relative rates
compared to hydrogen being 1,
that is, benzene when X is
hydrogen.
If X is methyl, it's 25 times
faster.
That is, if you have 25 times as
much benzene as toluene--
the one with methyl on it--
you'll get equal amounts of
the products at first, until
you've
used up all the toluene.
So it's 25 times faster.
So methyl helps the reaction.
OH really helps it, if you use
phenol it's 1,000 times faster
at getting the sum of all the
products.
Now why are those so fast?
Because electron donation eases
the formation of the
carbon cation intermediates.
Or, looked at a different way,
the carbon cations are stable
because there are other
electrons that become
stabilized when you get a cation
there.
For example, the unshared pair
on oxygen.
OK, now that's because we have
positive
charge at those locations.
When X is there, that helps out.
Now if you put NO2 as X, so it's
already there, then it's
6 times 10-(-8), it's 10- (-7),
million times slower.
And the same if you have
trimethyl ammonium with its
positive charge.
You don't want to make those
cations if there's another
cation there, or if there's an
NO2 group there.
So those are electron
withdrawing, and they retard
the formation of cation
intermediates.
The most interesting, as many
times, is the halogen.
The halogen is slower than
benzene, but not much slower.
Only 30 times slower.
And that's because both things
are happening with halogen.
It's withdrawing electrons in
the simga bond, but it has an
unshared pair that donates back,
so
that it mostly cancels.
Why is NO2 electron withdrawing
when OH is
electron donating?
O is more electron negative than
nitrogen, so you might
think that OH should be more
electron withdrawing.
An unshared pair on nitrogen is
higher energy than the
unshared pair on oxygen
should be more electron
donating.
So this seems, at first glance,
to be sort of nuts,
that OH is 1,000 times faster
and NO2 is 10
million times slower.
But it's pretty easy to
understand when you look at
the orbitals that are involved.
So in that case of oxygen,
there's this unshared pair on
the oxygen, which can overlap
with the p orbitals on the
benzene ring.
It turns out, indeed, that the
energy of the oxygen unshared
pair is about the same as pi
electrons of a
carbon-carbon bond.
So that the unshared pair on
oxygen has about  that energy,
about -1 on the scale we're
talking about here.
OK, so that's unusually high, as
pi are, unusually high.
So when you have a vacant
orbital next door, those
electrons get stabilized.
So it's a high HOMO, a good
overlap with phenyl, and
therefore OH can donate its
unshared pair.
OK, that's good.
How about NO2?
Notice that NO2 is allylic.
It's got three p orbitals on
each
oxygen and on the nitrogen.
So it's going to have a low
occupied molecular orbital
that gives good overlap with
phenyl.
So that one is able to donate
electrons because it has good
overlap, but it's not willing to
share its electrons.
Its electrons are very low in
energy.
They're not going to be much
stabilized by having a vacant
orbital next door.
So you're not going to get
anything out of that,
from the low one.
The next orbital of the NO2
allylic system has a node in
the middle.
That one.
That one has the energy shown in
yellow there, it's going to
be very good.
It's got a good, high HOMO.
As high as the p orbital on
oxygen, so it should be good
at donating electrons, at having
its electrons
stabilized by the vacant orbital
in the benzene ring.
But it's not, why not?
Can you see?
Why doesn't this orbital be
stabilized by mixing with
orbitals that are on the benzene
ring?
Because there's no overlap.
It doesn't have any size where
it's adjacent
to the benzene ring.
So it has no overlap, so it's
willing to give its electrons,
but it's not able because
there's no overlap.
And finally, you have the third
of the allylic
orbitals, that one.
Which is a low LUMO.
And it has good overlap with
phenyl.
So it withdraws electrons, it's
willing to take electrons
because it's unusually low, and
it has overlap so it's
able to accept electrons.
So that's why nitro is electron
withdrawing when OH
is electron donating.
it's because of that node in the
middle that makes it
unable to give electrons to the
benzene ring.
So NO2 is a pi accepter, whereas
OH is a pi donor.
OK now, we just looked at the
rates of these reactions, of
forming all three products
together.
But we might be interested in
the individual products,
ortho, meta, and para.
So let's look at that.
In the case of hydrogen, we'll
call each of these 1.
And now we'll do mixtures of
hydrogen with others--
but now we'll analyze the ones
that already have an X in
them-- we'll analyze whether
it's orth, meta, or para, and
how much of each one.
Now if it's methyl, you see that
two of them are very fast
but one of them is not fast,
compared to what it was when
only hydrogen is on the ring.
How do you understand the two
that are fast?
Why are those fast when X is
methyl?
Linda, do you have an idea?
When X up here is methyl, this
is good and this is good.
39 and 46.
But this one is not any better.
Methyl wants to be where the
cation is.
So it's especially good here,
and especially good here.
But not here.
There are only hydrogens here,
here, and here.
And it has the same rate as
hydrogen.
OK, that's fine.
If you look at t-butyl, now
again it's fast over here.
But it's not fast here.
So why don't you get this
product when you have the R
group here, when it's t-butyl?
You get it when you have methyl,
but
not when it's t-butyl.
Nathan, you got an idea?
STUDENT: Steric hindrance.
PROFESSOR: It's steric
hindrance, it's too big.
It's hard to put this extra
group here when you have
something big there already.
OK, so that's good.
Now there are two things about a
substituent, X. Does it make
it go faster, or does it make it
go slower, is it activating
or deactivating?
So it's activating, these are
faster than benzene.
And how is it directing, what
does it direct?
Its ortho and para, for the
reason we saw.
Except that in the t-butyl case,
it's not very much ortho
because of steric hindrance, as
Nathan told us.
OK, so those are electron
donating, and like to be
ortho/para, other things being
equal.
Now here's one that's the same
size as that neopentyl...
or t-butyl group,
the carbon with three methyls on
it.
But notice it's very much
slower.
And we saw that before.
But it's selectively slower,
it's slowed much more here--
0.6 times 10-(-8) than it is
here...
3 times 10-(-8).
So it's slow to get product, but
when you get product this
is the one you get.
Meta.
You don't get ortho and para.
Especially you don't get ortho
because
it's sterically hindered.
But you see, that's the same
thing.
If you want to form these things
when X has a plus
charge, don't put it here and
don't put it here.
If you're going to do it, put it
there.
Make it as far away as possible.
So that's meta.
And the same thing is true of
nitro.
It's slowed down everywhere.
But it's not nearly as slowed
down meta as it is here-- it's
slowed 10 times more here for
ortho and whatever--
300 times, right?
Yeah, 300 times slower when it's
para.
And if you have an ester group,
the same
kind of thing is true.
Here it's 10 times slower here
than here, and twice slower
here than there.
So those are deactivating, for
the reasons we talked about
before, and they're meta
directing.
But again, halogen, is
especially interesting.
Notice it's slowed down, it's
deactivating, but it's
ortho/para directing.
So it shows both these
characters, deactivating and
ortho/para.
Why?
It's deactivating because of the
electron
withdrawal, which is sigma.
But if you're going to make it,
at least make it where the
halogen's unshared pair can be
stabilized by the vacant
orbital next door.
Now, how can you make the
reaction work better, the
electrophilic substitution?
You can make the electrophile
better.
So C+ would be a great
nucleophile,
but you don't buy Cl+,
you have Cl2.
So what's the low LUMO here, in
Cl2?
I've asked this maybe 15 times
before in lecture.
STUDENT: Sigma*
PROFESSOR: Sigma*, OK.
But it's not nearly as low as
Cl+.
One way to make it better is to
treat it with a Lewis-acid
catalyst, like AlCl3, which has
a vacant orbital on
aluminum, which can attack an
unshared pair on the
chlorine like that.
And now you have a minus formal
charge on the aluminum
and plus on the chlorine.
It's a better leaving group.
So now you can do it better.
So Cl2 won't be nearly as
reactive as AlCl5.
Here, we can compare their LUMOs
and see it's essentially
the same LUMO.
But it's lower in the case of
AlCl5, so we can do this
reaction and it'll behave as if
it were Cl+.
If you look at the surface
charge, 0.29 positive there-- or
29 there, and 38 on the one with
AlCl3.
So it's a better electrophile.
So adding a Lewis acid makes
these things work better.
So the leaving group is then
AlCl4-,
rather than Cl-.
And remember before when we said
that the rate of addition
to alkenes of bromine is, in
some solvents, is second order
in bromine.
Because that second bromine
molecule makes the leaving
group Br3-, rather than Br-.
It makes the reaction better,
exactly the same idea here.
Another way to make the reaction
better is to activate
the nucleophile.
So salicylic acid, which was
studied by Kolbe the same
guy who excoriated van't Hoff
about stereochemistry
invented a way to make salicylic
acid.
So you start with phenol, you
react it with CO2, which has
that vacant orbital we talked
about, like
the one in NO2+.
So you could imagine that
reaction.
Just like NO2+, except that CO2
isn't nearly as low
as NO2 plus with its extra
proton.
But you can make the nucleophile
better.
In the previous slide, we saw
making the
electrophile better.
So here we have the unshared
pair on oxygen,
which helps us out.
But we can make it ever so much
better by putting base in
and making it a higher unshared
pair.
Now you have a big push to do
it, and you get salicylic
acid, which where aspirin comes
from, from
putting CO2 on phenol.
Now you could imagine the same
thing for NH2.
It's a higher unshared pair than
the
one on oxygen, normally.
So it would do this pushing too,
and you
could nitrate aniline
aminobenzene, it's called
aniline.
And in fact, this was the
proposed and, in fact, used in
1944 as a rocket fuel
a mixture of nitric acid and
aniline.
And there's a little story I'm
going to tell here about a
good friend of mine, Dennis
Tanner, who was a professor
for many years at the University
of Alberta.
But when he was a post-doc, he
was at Stanford.
And he's a very hard worker.
And he was working in the lab on
the Fourth of July.
Not many people were working on
the Fourth of July, but
several people were, and they
passed each other in the hall,
and they decided they should
have some fun, too.
So they decided that each person
would put on a display
out in the parking lot.
So Dennis had heard about this
being a self-igniting rocket
fuel, so he thought it would be
fun to mix to nitrate
aniline, to do the nitration of
aniline.
So he got concentrated nitric
acid and put it in a beaker,
and he got aniline and put it in
a separatory funnel and
hung it above the beaker.
And he crouched down and grabbed
the thing and twisted
it, and started to run.
But the instant it hit, before
he got more than two paces,
there was an enormous fireball
that burned off his eyebrows.
So indeed, this is a very, very
active nitration
reaction, as Dennis proved.
But you can tame it. if you put
an acetyl group on the
aniline, then you lower the
energy of the unshared pair.
The pi* of the carbonyl mixes
with it and lowers it.
Now you don't have so much of a
push anymore.
And now, the nitration still
takes place.
It's still ortho/para directing,
but it doesn't burn
your eyebrows off.
So the acetylation of aniline
makes this nitration
controllable.
So you can start with aniline,
react it with acetyl chloride
and pyridine, which is often
used as a catalyst for putting
acetyl groups on, and we'll talk
about that later.
And now you can do the
nitration.
And you see it's ortho/para
directing, not meta directing.
So the unshared pair is still
doing its work, but not as
dramatically, as in Dennis's
case.
But then if you really wanted to
do the nitration of
aniline, now you take the acetyl
group back off again.
So you have the product, so you
tamed the nitration.
Now I just want to introduce the
biographical part of this,
and we'll talk about the rest of
it next time.
So the Friedel-Crafts reaction
is one of the most important
electrophilic substitution
reactions.
In fact, it's one of the most
important reactions
altogether.
And it was named after Charles
Friedel
and James Mason Crafts.
Friedel was a Frenchman.
Notice he's seven years older
than
Crafts, who was an American.
So this is a great example of
where America stood in
international science in the
last part of the 19th century.
So these are the publications of
James Mason Crafts from
1862, when he was a student,
until 1915 when he died.
So some of his papers were on
organic chemistry, and they
didn't have Friedel as a
co-author.
And at different ages,
he published a number as a
student there, as you'll see.
But then kept publishing.
Now here's his trajectory.
He was born in Boston, he
studied at Harvard.
But then to learn real science,
he went to Europe.
First he went to Germany for
just a short period.
He worked with Bunsen, actually.
Then he went to France and
worked with Wurtz, the
successor of Dumas.
And he stayed there for four
years.
And then he came back, he
actually inspected mines in
Mexico for a year--
and California.
Then he went to Cornell--
which had just been founded--
to be the chemistry professor
for a couple of years.
Then he went to MIT.
And then he was ill, but also
tired of not doing research.
And he went back to Paris.
He went back for just two years,
but he
stayed for 17 years.
And now he was working with his
pal, Friedel, whom he'd
met as a student in Wurtz's lab.
Then he came back to MIT and, in
fact, he was president of
MIT for two years around 1900.
Now here are his papers that are
not organic chemistry.
They're about thermometry, about
physical chemistry.
And notice he did most of the
publication during this second
period in Paris when he was
doing only research.
But if you look at his papers
with Friedel, there are an
enormous number.
During this period--when he
was in America,
he published almost nothing.
When he was in Paris, he
published a lot, both as a
student when he started working
with Friedel, and
especially after he came back in
these 17 years.
So he published 100 papers
during these years, 99 papers
during those years.
So it wasn't possible to do the
kind of research in this
country that you could do over
there.
And then in 1877, just after he
had gone back to recover
and work with his pal Friedel at
the School of Mines, they
published a really important
paper and most of those red
publications after that are
about this
Friedel Crafts reaction.
And they got into it because
they had been students
together working with Wurtz.
And we'll talk about this then
next time.